[Musik]
deutschland in der spargel krise das ist
meine chance systemrelevant zu sein und
außerdem bin ich gerade ziemlich pleite
und braucht dringend kohle und so schwer
wird ja wohl nicht sein
[Musik]
hallo ich bin der lutz ja schön ich bin
herr kister ja herr kister ist freut
mich ich will helfen ich will auch
spargel stechen und ich sag mal kann ja
nicht so das große problem sein oder
die leute stellen sich ein bisschen an
wir wollen mit der gießkanne hier
ich dachte dass mal ein bisschen gießt
vor dem stechen wo kommen sie her aus
köln habe mir gedacht ja wir stellen
sich vor
also ich gehe jetzt erstmal da ganz
vorurteilsfrei raten also ich hab mich
jetzt auch nicht groß vorbereitet merken
sie sich einen satz der spargelstecher
stich spanne mit dem spargeld
stechmesser und legt den gestochenen
spargel in die spargelstecher kiste der
spargelstecher stich den spargel stechen
[Musik]
weiß oder grün das nicht
im wasser ziehen
sogar der grossbank hat seine großmama
ach ist doch was vom sparen
spargel ist das hier eine weiße wieder
aussieht ja ja magst du sprache ja vor
allem die köpfchen ist mag am liebsten
weil die köpfchen rest schmeiße ich weg
was zu viel geld also vor carola hatte
ich hatte ich doch zu viel geld also
jetzt er sich auch den ganzen sport so
wo ist hier in diesem gebiet wo steht
hier sprach ja gar nicht so einfach
dreck erst mal zu meiner form der
spargel der hebt in einer gewissen form
den boden an und das geübte auge sieht
hat ich behaupte ich spare der fünf
zentimeter unter der erde unsere
normalen polnischen und rumänischen
mitarbeiter die können dann auch dort
über der erde stecken wie du dass
frieden in meiner karriere schon ein
habe ich auch noch nicht gemacht ja aber
warum ist das denn so dass deutsche kein
spargel stechen können nutzer das ist so
bei dem mit dem können ich habe so eine
sache wir glauben wir können das nicht
wir kommen aus wohlstands region wurde
eigentlich nicht mehr angebracht ist in
der nahrungsmittelproduktion zu arbeiten
gab es schon deutsche die jetzt hier
hingekommen sind haben wir euch probiere
das war ja und die meisten auch dass die
meisten sind nach zwei tagen gescheitert
123 ja ja und jetzt das messer an den
spargel heran für jahr an zwei fingern
fingerbreit so naja und russland ist
echt doch wenn er die hebel ja ist ja
das gleiche
ach scheiße von liebermann mindert die
glöckner sie hier
klöckner klappt aber nicht frage
gesprochen
die meisten haben da ist noch alles was
macht man denn jetzt in dem fall
hochsprache der kommt auch in die kiste
wenn wir das buch gilt verkauft dann
muss man das köpfchen muss man ja nicht
scheitern bin ich hatte spezialist für
bruch sparen würde ja da bin ich aber
gehe ich mit corona pleite oder mit der
pleite
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute show
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal der stelle
[Musik]